good management been offering bad
management and Arthur jinhua if he can
recreate some of the stuff we've done
for nice and Newcastle isn't Marty I
believe I can get my own Dominion are
that I also write a little bit too much
on maybe so championship manager and not
real life but you know
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you blast from the past year I'm gonna
take Robinho first you're a bit flair to
start my team I decide to get flash back
there did you bend the toss I won the
toss there when when we were waiting for
you to get on the call I think I won the
tie family I'm gonna pack CC for one
reason and one reason only for that goal
against Chelsea Lord Obafemi Martins he
was like one of the years when I used to
play pro Evolution a lot he was like
unreal like so fast he was like he's so
good in that game I'm not sure if he was
that as good in real life so I'm gonna
go with dark fight and I'm gonna take
him because I think I need a bit of work
ethic alongside Robinho's you've
absolutely stole my back there Mitra
that first season for Swansea name had
what happened to the game you made
messin yeah well if I go for him from
the Swansea days I think that's that's a
very lazy front to I just what Paul in
between the gym or I'm gonna take a rest
I'm gonna go up I'm gonna go on meet you
up top
[Music]
I'm gonna go with nor no bear so Solano
oh I think I'm gonna I need to go by it
I mean I a also not sort of known for a
sort of work ethic feeling pretty good
about my team right now I think I'm
going yeah it's just whether it's just
where that what we're advancing or if
I'm gonna take Pettersen yeah just I
just stick with him I'm gonna have a
great balance
now with this I need to go in the
transfer market by Patterson awful
that's what I did I needed a workhorse
and I'm not gonna get it good memories
been been offering bad memories but then
I thought you know what if he can
recreate some of the stuff it doesn't
for nice and Newcastle is unmarked team
I believe I can get modified them again
what are that come on happened I think
you're gonna need to do it over here
dear players all of them so far yeah I
need their join me again and Medfield
join me yes I've just I've just scrolled
down to look at the central there's an
adult except those sorts of players in
ha
[Music]
I'm gonna take Riquelme I used to sign
him all the time and championship
manager like when yeah when I played
that and you use a yeah he was
unbelievable in that eating a heart
walking in there I'm sure disappointed
there if you want hard work go for
trapped he was he was known hey Katie
please probably one of the best players
gonna go AG Okocha okay yeah I probably
would have taken him I would have
probably taken him next I'm gonna go and
this is again for me championship
manager I'm taking I'm are wants to play
the one championship manager
yeah like far too much championship
manager but it's a great game I'm gonna
go Niko Lonza
[Music]
okay here we got here I'm gonna take
first I'm gonna go with Ian heart item a
bunch of years in fancy football and he
was at you as a point machine so I'm I'm
gonna only take him at left-back I think
I'm gonna take plane Johnson it right
back do a bit of Liverpool buyers there
in that pick I mean slightly misleading
okay
right back I'm gonna take Raphael solid
pick that please we figured or hope he's
one of the strongest guys around me he
could talk to plank for a bit ten
minutes easy used to do that you know
yeah I'm gonna go ahead and I think when
you look back when you look back and
Sega doors collapse I think you'll be
surprised that oh good ears
[Music]
Amoruso loved a red card Denis yeah
there yeah yeah I'm not taking him I
want some discipline in there I'm gonna
take Chris Samba because I think I think
he's gonna be he's gonna be scoring some
goals with the guys I've got taken to
set pieces I want I'm not gonna lie I
wanted Samba I think I'm gonna call
Orson you know I'm I'm gonna take Philip
Metz's and I'm gonna take him this is
another championship manager che use
they always like you know one of the
Wonder kids I'm trying to get
partnerships I'm trying to link them up
I'm trying to get them to bring the bass
knowing each other and that's why I'm
going to go Mel bear they would be mad
too and the changing room they get the
team going yeah you need that when
things get tough you need somebody left
you up and Lawson
Milberg and the heart defense will see
you through in games
[Music]
I mean I would like to take sheila bair
but I don't think I needed I've got
enough set-piece takers so I'm gonna go
with Dida I think he would have had the
best career at a lot of them yeah yeah I
think I'm gonna gorgeous little bit
shocked yeah well like it's delectable
maybe as possessed to be honest that
like I didn't really watch a lot of
family structure theory actually how
good at keeping it was but what I can
tell you is he won level for the
Champions League and that's an afternoon
technically matching ones hands don't
technically that's it yeah technically
my hat but unfortunately football
involves running as well and some of my
players like button and so I think
you've went maybe too hard working I
think you've been third yeah so hard
working every bet you you focus on too
much discipline and hard work that
you've not got the Flair that maybe is
required
sure well I'm all about substance though
I'm all about substance not just sort of
showing off get the job done but I'm
realistically going for a 5-4 vet okay I
think overall yeah I think I I think I
got the better of that but we'll see
what everyone else thinks I also write a
little bit too much on maybe so
championship manager and not real life
but you know
[Music]
[Music]
you
you